[Music]
you guys my name is Rhea butcher it's
not a fake name it's funny because it's
true
I am butcher than all of you and by like
a lot I can tell when I got here a valet
came running across the street said oh
my god
hey God thank god you're here we have a
bunch of manual transmission cars and
none of us can park them please help us
I said how many got ten I'll take two at
a time let's get this thing done did it
right up I like to think about my
ancestors back in a cave like in West
Virginia trying to figure out what last
name they're gonna go with and one of
them says one day we'll have the most
lesbian great-granddaughter so from this
day forward we shall be known as butcher
and then the prophecy was fulfilled I am
on Conan with this haircut
I also love having this last name
because I am a lifetime vegetarian the
last name butcher had that irony my
entire life but not too much iron in my
diet very weak honestly don't even know
how I'm standing here my muscles are
just made out of sunflower seeds in Hope
when I were a Fitbit it just counts
wishes tells me to go back to bed my mom
was a vegetarian when she was pregnant
with me that's how long I've been a
vegetarian in utero I was born this way
both ways
[Applause]
she got an ultrasound and it was just a
cube of tofu she was like is it a girl
or a boy and the doctor is like we're
not sure and honestly I'm still not
doctors like but we do know it's Silk'n
that is a tofu joke for you
I don't know I don't know if you guys
can tell by this rock-a-doodle haircut
and this off-duty lesbian tractor
mechanic outfit
I have on a tractor mechanic that
escaped from a 1940's prison but it did
take me a while to come out to my family
I think for a couple of reasons I'm from
Akron Ohio from Ohio originally I like
to call Ohio the thinking man's Indiana
a lot of my family from Ohio myself
included we're hillbillies you might be
like how hillbilly could you possibly be
well you know that phrase shooting fish
in a barrel
I've done that it requires a lot of
skill but I think the biggest reason it
took me a while to come out to my family
specifically my parents is they've been
divorced my entire life I was born in
August of 1982 and they're divorced in
September 1982 I like to think I had a
little hand in that little tiny baby
hand I'm also an only child which was
super fun when I was growing up I didn't
have to share my Hemans or my shira's or
my my pal - or my my pet monster or my
my buddy but as an only child there's a
genre of toys that's pretty rough and
that is board games so I like to share
with you guys my top three worst board
games for being an only child
number three Hungry Hungry Hippos
I win number two is twister I went again
and the number one worst board game for
being an only child is don't wake daddy
because he doesn't live here anymore
that was a twofer if I can leave you
guys with one thought it would be this
the band tool has made some interesting
music sure but I think there are a
greater gift to the world at large is
the fact that they got a ton of dudes to
walk around in a t-shirt that says to
Lana
[Applause]
you